>> MEIER: Good morning everyone, and welcome
yet another attempt at The App Clinic of video
players.
But before we get started, you know, we're
going to be reviewing these video player apps.
And frankly I don't really understand what
the big deal is.
I mean, I've had a look at the code.
And as far as I can see, this is all we need
to do, right?
We just need to, you know, get a video to
view, put it somewhere on my screen, and then
it's just a simple matter of passing in different
URLs, right?
I mean, if that's all there is too it, what's
the challenge?
Why are there--why are these apps popular?
Why can't people just, you know, build it
themselves.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure.
Your ignorance astounds me.
You might think that of course, having a video
view that's so easy to use would make it very
easy to write a video app.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: The truth is in software, things
that are very easy to use are often not very
powerful.
And that's exactly the way that video player
turned out.
Now, we started way back in the--in the early
days of Android, with media playback via the
MediaPlayer API.
Of course, that's what we just saw with this
sim, that's actually a one call fire and forget
way of playing back video.
A MediaPlayer is really easy to use.
But it's probably too easy to use, especially
if you're looking for professional custom
solutions.
It's basically a black box.
If you have any kind of special needs, you're
out luck.
For instance, MediaPlayer is hardware accelerated.
But, it's hardware accelerated differently
on different platforms, on different versions
EOS and different OEM devices.
And there's no way to find out what type of
hardware acceleration you're getting.
>> MEIER: Huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, that's not really a problem
if you don't want customization because you're
always guaranteed that an Android device will
playback H2--H.264 baseline profile.
A lot of people don't like baseline profile
though especially people who have already
encoded for other devices.
>> MEIER: Shocked.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, when we launched Honeycomb,
we decided to make some improvements and we
supported an API called OpenMAX AL.
Now, the truth is OpenMAX AL was not necessarily
our first choice because it's not a Java API.
But, it is a cron standard, much like OpenGL
and allowed us to get some of the professional
features that we were looking for.
So, if you wanted professional features in
Honeycomb and in Ice Cream Sandwich, OpenMAX
AL is a great choice.
The drawback is you've got to write your code
in C. With Ice Cream Sandwich we also introduced
a new way of working with video, and that
was the texture review and service view.
So these--the ability to actually work with
video textures allowed you to do some more
interesting things like real time video effects.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: But things didn't really get
real until Jelly Bean.
Jelly Bean is the apotheosis of video APIs,
by which I mean we have a Java API that works.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Jelly Bean supports what we call
MediaCodec.
A MediaCodec is not an easy to use API by
any means.
But it's a sort of API that if you are a professional
that writes video apps for a living and understands
media.
You're going to love it or at least hate it
considerably less.
>> MEIER: Minimizing hate factor, that's what
we're all about.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
It gives you low level access to the media
acceleration hardware and it gives you an
API to query what formats the hardware supports.
So like I said, it's not a simple API by any
means.
But it is professional and it supports most
of the used cases and corner cases that a
really nice video player needs.
And we'll see some of those used cases as
we look at the apps.
For instance, as I mentioned media player
will only hardware accelerate certain formats.
>> MEIER: I see.
>> NI-LEWIS: And you don't necessarily know
what formats those are.
So, it's impossible with media player to make
an application that claims to support every
format or even a large number of formats.
And I think, we noticed that one of the selling
points to the players that we're looking at
today, is how many different media formats
they support.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
That was one of the biggest things which most
of them claimed, was which media formats they
support...
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: ...being able to play things back.
>> NI-LEWIS: And without MediaCodec, your
stuck with two unattractive choices.
You can either only support the baseline formats
that are hardware accelerated across all Android
devices.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or you do everything with a software
decoder and don't support hardware decoding
at all.
>> MEIER: Right.
And that's going to result in worse playback,
right?
>> NI-LEWIS: In general, or at the very least
a lower battery life, because a software implementation
is going to require a lot more power since...
>> MEIER: That makes sense.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's being done the CPU and
you know, less efficient SOC--part of the
SOC.
>> MEIER: There you go.
That was educational.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
So let's talk about, if you decided to make
a media app.
>> MEIER: Indeed.
>> NI-LEWIS: What should it be?
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So, let's have a look.
So these are the--these are the criteria which
we are looking for.
The prescriptions if you will for making a
great video player app.
And I think we want to break this down into
two general categories.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure.
These are the main two pieces of functionality
that every video app we looked at has.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
And you'll note also that we--the apps that
we're looking at here are video players.
So this is apps where you're playing back
video that you've already downloaded, put
on to your device somehow rather than apps
which are designed for discovering content.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So this isn't Hulu or Netflix.
This isn't a Google Play or a streaming service.
This is all about, you've gotten video, you
know, from your camcorder or you downloaded
it from one of these sources.
And you want to take a look at it.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
So there's--the two categories are Browsing
and Playback.
So for Browse, it's really about easy organization.
It's about being able to discover the information
that you've already got on your device.
And so you've got one or two videos, then
that should be really straight forward.
But, you've got to think in terms of scale.
What if you've got, you know, tens or hundreds
of videos that you want to be able to browse
through.
What's that experience like?
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, we sort of went through
a lot of this with audio...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...playback apps when we talked
about those about a month ago and how one
thing that can make or break an app is how
easy it is to discover the content that you
want to play and ignore the content that you
don't.
And one of the most important things that
a video app can do in the browse mode is,
respect to the .nomedia file, that a lot of
game developers for instance will download
a bunch of AVIs or MPEG4s to a media directory,
so that they can play it later on in the game.
Now, because that's not a universally accessible
global media directory that's meant to be
played by anyone.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: They'll stick a .nomedia file
inside that directory, and if you don't respect
that.
>> MEIER: You need a little noise.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, absolutely.
You're going to get cut scenes from games
that you didn't even know existed.
And a lot times they don't have very informative
names.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: That ends up being kind of a
spoiler really.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
And you don't know what that is until it's
the end scene from a game that you're halfway
through playing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> MEIER: So as...
>> NI-LEWIS: Thanks a lot, Bard's Tale is
ruined for me.
>> MEIER: In terms of playback, it's kind
of what you'd expect.
And again, what we've sort of described already
in terms of why you're building these apps
to begin with.
And it's the ability to be able to play back
pretty much anything.
So I don't want to have to think about what
the codecs are, how it's being transcoded.
I just want to copy stuff onto the device
and have it played back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And I wanted to it efficiently as
well, so hardware decoding where possible.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
I also wanted to have my app support subtitles.
This is really important for hearing impaired
people.
To me, it's important because I like to watch
foreign language films.
My wife does not speak English as a foreign
or as a first language.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You have some problems with American
I believe Reto, so...
>> MEIER: That's right.
It can get confusing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
So, you need to have those subtitles just
incase.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And the last thing we wanted to talk about
was the notification bar or status bar.
Being the real one, and we saw a lot of apps
trying to sort of, half take our advice here
and say, "Oh well people say that they want
to have their status bar visible because they
want to see what the time is.
They want to see, you know, that sort of information,
battery life, wifi connectivity..."
>> NI-LEWIS: Well and of course they weren't
taking our advice.
I mean, these are features these apps have
had for a long time.
>> MEIER: Yeah, apparently.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's obvious that people want
to be able to see the sorts of things that
they see in a notification bar, battery life
and the clock being two very important once.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But if you're going to show that
already.
Why not just support all of these cases.
When I have a notification, I want to be able
to pull it down.
I want to know if I need to stop watching
my video because there's an important meeting
that I completely forgot about.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So let's have a look at the apps which we're
going to check out today.
So the poor app developers for these apps
who have been waiting for two or three weeks
now for this feedback, but we're going to
be looking at MX Player, CineXPlayer and DICE
player.
So three video playing apps there.
So, let's get started, I guess.
Let's kick off of it.
The first step we wanted to look at was CineXPlayer.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And as you can see we've got the--they've
got a feature graphic which is really nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, and the feature graphic
here is nicely done.
But, I wouldn't use this one personally.
>> MEIER: Yeah, I mean, you can see we're
looking at a confidence model.
It's from a fair distance away.
And you can't really read the name of the
app from here.
It fades into the background, the contrast
isn't really high enough, and the words are
too small.
>> NI-LEWIS: No, all I see is X with maybe
an E and something that's either an R or an
X.
>> MEIER: Next to it, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Who can say?
So that, you know, they've got the table stakes
here, they've got the ability to be featured
or promoted in Google Play by having a feature
graphic which is really important...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...but they haven't taken advantage
of it.
We've seen just recently people blogging,
talking about the fact that just having a
better feature graphic can have significant
impact and your downloads, should you be fortunate
enough to be promoted.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
I can--I can guarantee that for this one they
wouldn't run it.
They--this would get kicked back to the developer
just because it's eligible at those--at those
dimensions.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, what--why don't you show
me what the CineXPlayer does, you know.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, we've got our fancy
HDMI set up, does not work today and the reason
is that most video apps do not actually display
the UI out of the HDMI port so instead what
we've got is a--an even fancier and far more
expensive solution on the...
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...in this high-tech home movie
camera pointed at the screen here so we'll
go ahead and...
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...see how that works today.
>> MEIER: Sort of camera you expect to see--seeing
in the movie Super 8 primarily.
Probably the one's filming the movie Super
8 rather than be featured in the movie Super
8.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: So, this is CineX and so CineXPlayer
so you can see straight away we've opened
it up.
We've got a really customized display or at
least you can see part of it with the--with
the reflection.
But that kind of makes the point and then
it is a--it is a very dark looking display.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
I'm not going to complain actually...
>> MEIER: No, that's fine.
>> NI-LEWIS: You don't want to make complains
about the other apps it's that they're too
white.
>> MEIER: Too white.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Yeah.
Yes.
>> MEIER: And part of the--but the big deal
here is that it is entirely gray.
We've got these massive areas here for thumbnails
which are populated which is a little bit
surprising presuming that this--that these
movies can be played back.
It's kind of weird that you wouldn't display
something.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that was the thing that
really confused me is it felt like we had
a thumbnail area but there's no thumbnail
anywhere I mean, I...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Even on, you know camcorder videos
and stuff that I completely expected to have
a thumbnail the things that even had a thumbnail
in the gallery.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Are not shown with thumbnails,
so I--did they just run out of time or...
>> MEIER: It's hard to say.
It's disappointing though because I mean,
this is--a video playing app is very visual
that's kind of the point.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And so part of creating that immersive
experience is to have the thumbnails here
so that you're immediately drown into--to
watch one of these things.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Really--about all these apps is
about engagement and I think we're lacking
here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I think we're, you know,
we don't want to spend too much more time
on this black screen so why don't we...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Why don't we go ahead and play
this week in Android development.
Oh.
>> MEIER: Can't be done.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> MEIER: Disappointing.
So, it's nice that they gave you the ability
to report it but disappointing that it is
not able to play back.
What--it seems to be a reasonably standard
and encoded MP4.
>> NI-LEWIS: Being the MP4 that you pirated
off in YouTube.
>> MEIER: Yes, that's you know, well, I'd
like to think it is the MP4 that I uploaded
to YouTube rather than the one I pulled down
from YouTube.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Now, I just noticed that my--that my microphone
here is falling off and so we probably a need
a lot of dialogue help-in post.
But I mean, let me just clip that right back
on here.
>> MEIER: Which is a nice change.
>> NI-LEWIS: [INDISTINCT] everybody like,
I--but I was too loud today.
>> MEIER: So let's close this then.
So, it does give you the ability report which
presumably will give then the ability to get
feedback on what encoding types they don't
support.
But we can go back here and click on this
other video and have that play back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: And so right away we can see as
we disappear here.
We've kind of got partially immersive but
not really, I mean, it's thumbnail but that's
fine because it is a very small, a very low
resolution proof.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah, well this--is this
Technicolor?
>> MEIER: It is.
It is Technicolor.
>> NI-LEWIS: Can we--can we get it to--there
we go.
>> MEIER: There you go.
So, we can blow it up so you can have the
Native resolution or blow it up to full which
is nice.
And we go full screen but we don't really
go full screen not--yeah, you can see on the
display that the navigation along the bottom
is too visible.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, is that a fridge.
Okay.
>> MEIER: It could be.
Has--as this is the standard notification
so my--it kind of feels like my status bar
should have gone away and if this was running
on a phone I can tell you that it would, that
the status bar would have disappeared but
because this isn't targeting tablet devices,
these aren't targeting Android 11.
We have the mini button it's kind of shameful
and what it's doing here but it's all the
standard menu button of shame.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I cant you that--not targeting
Android 11 it's actually the main problem
with this app.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But Android technology is we
just learned has moved on considerably from
the old Ginger and Froyo days where we didn't
have a particularly good system wide store
for video and now we've got so much better
APIs.
The hard work has come along considerably
the framework now supports a much--not only
much better video playback but also much more
interesting UI Organization.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a shame that CineXPlayer
is not enough with the times and that way.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So, again, so the big thing here which would
be nice to see--so they've actually implemented
this pseudo notification bar along the top
here, which does have--let's see if I can
pause and that'll stop.
So it does have the time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: It has the battery life as well
so it's trying to give us the sort of information
which would normally be in my notification
bar but frankly I just want my notification
bar back and in this instance is not even
getting rid of it so it's sort of a redundant.
A few other things which, you know, which
I wanted to mention while we're looking at
CineXPlayer, the menu button which I already
mentioned this should be bringing up a menu
ideally as part of an ActionBar overflow menu.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And what you're looking at here
is really settings.
We should leave behind the settings dialogue.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: What you can see at the bottom here
is which is really nice is that they have
used the audio effects APIs in Android which
is allowing you to modify things like treble,
bass, 3D effect and bass boost which is all
part of the Android media effects framework
which is a really nice feature for them to
build in.
>> NI-LEWIS: That is cool.
All right.
Oh, I think that that gives us a good idea
of what CineXPlayer is about.
Let's go ahead and go on to our next victim.
>> MEIER: Uh-huh, absolutely.
So, I think the next, oh, well, before we
do move on there is one thing I wanted to
mention which is if you look at the--at the
market listing of the Google Play listing
for this app.
They mentioned that they require the phone
state permission to be able to listen when
you've got incoming calls presumably to pause,
playback and do sensible things.
Now as it happens that probably over thinking
it.
So, Android does already give you a way to
be able to know when things like that happened.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Most basic of which is little pause
your activity.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: So.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: When that happens it's probably
a good time to just pause and put everything
in stasis.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, another note on that
here I've noticed that this is--in my opinion
what separates the more professional developers
from the less professional developers, I don't
know.
I think you and I have discussed before we're
both readers every now and then we take a
look at the website called the dailywtf.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And it seemed like 90% of the
WTF moments on that site come from a developer
finding some convoluted way to get the result
they want and not asking, gee, is there a
better way to his like instead of writing
200 lines of date and time parsing code in
Java wouldn't you want to use the date time
class and wouldn't a wise developer think
to themselves I wonder if such a thing is
a date time class exist.
>> MEIER: It reminds me of my graphics class,
one of my first graphics class at college
where we're giving--given a task to draw a
circle...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...on a canvas.
And so we all disappeared into the lab and
after a few moments most of us had the, uh-huh,
moment when, "Oh, canvas.drawCircle."
That was not enough to display some of the
more intrepid folks who had all the arch signs
and cosigns and were building the whole thing
through a series loops and it's like that,
very impressive and entirely a waste of time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Admirable, but yes.
Unless you're--unless you're doing this from
the ground up on 1980s there are hardware
there is probably an accelerated routine in
there that you would never be able to write
on your own because...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you don't have access to those
particular parts of the framework and those
particular parts of the hardware.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And this is a good example of
that if you--if you find yourself in a place
where you need to make the Android device
do something or you need to do something in
response to what the Android device is doing.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And you find yourself writing
convoluted code that asks "What is the user
doing or am I on a tablet so I know whether
to rotate into portrait...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...or landscape" or you just
doing a lot of queries.
Chances are--and this is not always true but
there's a really...
>> MEIER: The good chance.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...high likelihood that you're
going to be able to find something, some of
that you can just catch in the Android framework
and if for some reason that doesn't suffice
if you found a place where let's say on pause
does not give you the information you need
to pause then that's a bug and that should
be reported.
>> MEIER: That's right.
And we will--yeah, we would definitely listen
to that with interest.
In terms of audio playback in fact there is
a one additional step you can take which is
listen for the lost of audio focus.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: So, you may find that, you know,
while you're watching a movie that we have
some other audio app starts playing and you
want to be able to pause when that happens
you can listen to the listen for lost of audio
focus and pause your playback at the same
time and there is in fact in Android training
class called managing audio playback which
will give you all the information you need
to do exactly that.
>> NI-LEWIS: And read that class because even
apps which correctly catch audio focus change
messages have done some horrible, horrible
things.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: What was the one we were just
looking at an app which, actually in response
to audio focus change, started playing something
a zero volume stream that was muted.
>> MEIER: Oh, that's helpful.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And for some reason I don't know the whole
story but after playing that app nothing else
would play in the entire whole system.
>> MEIER: Interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because it...
>> MEIER: Perhaps it never gave back audio
focus.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: It had just decided to play a zero
volume focus.
That's impressive.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MEIER: So, the next app which we wanted
to look at is MX Player.
Now, this is an app that's I think you looked
at in more detail, but I've been fact used
this one a little bit myself.
So, we're both a little bit familiar.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I think we both ended up really enjoying the
playback functionality of this.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Although I was a little disappointed
in the browsing functionality.
Now, you don't have quite as much on your
device as I did.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: But you--it starts out with this
really simple browsing interface.
Now, unfortunately it has something that looks
like an action bar.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But it doesn't really act like
an action bar.
There's no navigation.
There's no auto affordance.
>> MEIER: Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, when I moved down into these
movies folder for instance.
Although I get pretty much what you expect.
>> MEIER: Now you get the file now, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: There's no way for me to move
up.
>> MEIER: Oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: And there's no real indication
that I've moved into a different location
in the hierarchy.
Now, once I had several different folders
and play list and alternate locations...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...on my device.
I found that to be sort of disorienting.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: I didn't really like not knowing
where I was in the--in the general hierarchy
of my device.
It might just be me.
>> MEIER: No.
I think it's an interesting point and something
consistent between all of these apps which
is at the browsing experience doesn't seem
optimized for content discovery.
So, I can see where these apps will probably
come from as people who have this content
and they wanted to view it on their tablets.
The Native MediaPlayer can do the job and
so they build apps to do that.
So, knowing what's on there and having it
already in a directory structure and, you
know chance is it's probably going to be enough
for them to understand.
But as you're trying to build something for
more people to use who didn't build the app,
you really need to make things like navigation
much more prominent.
So, people who didn't design it still understand
how it works.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I feel like the--in this case the navigation
is workman like.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: It certainly does the job but
it doesn't show the sort of craft that we've
come to expect out of the top Android apps.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that's sad because the playback
screen...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
This is where it really...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is really amazing.
>> MEIER: ...really shines.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
So, I'm going to resume watching--I'm still
getting Android developments.
The playback is great, immediately comes full
screen.
When I decide to bring up the UI it gives
me not only a nice--a nicer UI.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, with this a little
less of extrusive.
But also let's me know for instance am I hardware
accelerated or...
>> MEIER: Oh, I use software or hardware decoded,
nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It let's me choose.
It does have--you know, we didn't see all
of this on the--on the tablet but on the phone
I believe it does actually bring up the real
notification bar and...
>> MEIER: Well, indeed.
And you can see that...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...if we hit play here we'll--oh
no, it doesn't--it does.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
So, it goes...
>> MEIER: So, you can see everything's disappeared
and in fact even the navigation here.
So, it's using the Android 4.0, you know,
low profile stuff.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: And on a phone it will do exactly
that.
So, it gives you this completely immersive
experience.
No notifications, no clocks, nothing.
As soon as you hit the screen, boom.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: You get it all back.
You get the status bar.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: You get the action bar.
You get status and navigation the whole thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I like that it keeps the
UI up when I'm paused, right?
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: It has a very nice scrubbing
functionality here.
>> MEIER: Very nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: It also has some gestures which
I think are really interesting.
The moving left to right in the middle of
the screen will scrub for a little bit more
sensitivity.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And then on one side of the screen
you get brightness.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: And then on the other side you
get volume.
>> MEIER: Very nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, that's a cool innovation.
>> MEIER: Yeah, definitely.
I like that.
>> NI-LEWIS: But what I found most valuable
of all.
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because I have an 18 month--18
month-year-old girl, she absolutely loves
to watch videos of her mommy and of herself
and not of me but...
>> MEIER: Who can blame her?
>> NI-LEWIS: But it drives her nuts, drives
me not when the video goes away because she
pressed to the wrong area of the screen.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: And she doesn't know anything
about soft buttons or the back button, the
home key or the apps switcher.
>> MEIER: It's all just screen.
>> NI-LEWIS: She just knows that mommy went
away and she doesn't know why.
So, one innovation that I thought was really,
really interesting here is this child mode.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Where you press.
I'm going to go ahead and bring it out again.
While you're playing back you can press this
little lock button
and that puts you into lockout mode.
So, anything you do on the screen will have
no effect except for pressing this tiny little
lock button.
>> MEIER: You happen to press the little tiny
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it doesn't completely solve
the 18-month-old problem, but it does mean
that she's much less likely to hit that tiny
little button correctly than she is to...
>> MEIER: Even with her little fingers.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: That's interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, it requires a better long
press too which is also...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...a little bit difficult for
her.
>> MEIER: Do you know they--how they went
implementing that?
>> NI-LEWIS: I have no idea.
I have absolutely no idea how they did it
or whether the way they did it.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Is considered kosher in any way.
>> MEIER: It doesn't seem it's finally legit
even if it is very useful.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, I'm really, really looking
forward to having a conversation with the
framework team and with the developers and
see how they went about it.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because although I think it breaks
a lot of Android rules, on the other hand
it's awesome.
>> MEIER: It's kind of useful.
>> NI-LEWIS: So...
>> MEIER: That's always an interesting challenge.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, in general this app scores
big on two counts.
First is that it's got a really nice UI.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And second it doesn't remove
you from the normal Android experience.
So, as you--as you go out of the full screen
mode you still have the normal Android action
bar and the...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...notification bar.
Everything that you want.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: The only thing--I said action
bar but I meant notification bar.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But speaking of action bar, in
the browser that really should be a real action
bar.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, why isn't it to the real
action bar?
>> MEIER: Well, probably because we haven't
released a compatible action bar.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
That seems like a...
>> NI-LEWIS: Although...
>> MEIER: ...reasonable alternative because
of that.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...many of the things that they're
doing can't be supported in anything below
Jelly Bean.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it would be nice I think.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Well, they don't have particular complex browser
which is one the...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...you know the comments that we
had.
And so it seemed like the work involved to
get a real action bar and give that negative
feel for the more advanced devices would be
worthwhile an investment at this point.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, just one last note on this
browser and I think we could make this comment
about a lot of apps is that this sort of little
thumbnail on the left side of the listview
with gigantic amounts of white space around
it.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Is really getting old and some
of the newer apps that we've been very impressed
by lately and...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they're doing well in the
Google Play Store has gone to a completely
different tiled view with large thumbnails.
The title's overlaid on an alpha blended background.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, you don't get any white space
at all.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I think that ends up being
a much more pleasant browsing experience.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And again, you know, it's just--you've got
this wonderfully immersive video playback
experience.
It would be wonderful to have that as part
of the browsing experience as well.
And really make this much more like a gallery.
Frankly, I love more like the way that the
YouTube app works.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And that you open it up and you
kind of get this wall of video.
And that's obviously very specific to YouTube.
But it's that sort of feel of trying to immerse
you in content which makes you feel all the
more willing in desire or sort of being able
to just stop playing stuff back and see what's
behind each of those windows.
>> NI-LEWIS: At the same time--let's face
it.
We're going to spend 2% of our time browsing
and 98% of our time watching, you know.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: This definitely delivers the
goods when it comes to watching.
Now, nearly as good in that department is
our next app DICE Player.
But I think before we talk about that we wanted
to discuss a few more coding questions.
>> MEIER: Indeed.
So, one of the things which I really like
about MX Player was the fact that it handled
that immersive experience correctly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: So, we got rid of all of my cron,
but then brought it all back as soon as I
pressed the button.
And so if you're wondering how to I do that,
well, here's the code that tells you.
So, for Android 4 and above, what you want
to do is actually set the system visibility
options to SYSTEM_UI_FLAG_HIDE_NAVIGATION.
So, what that will do was actually remove
all the cron, the status bar, the navigation,
the notification bar, everything on Android
4 devices.
And you'll note that at the same time as we
set that flag we're also going to set a listener
which is going to set the UI flag either visible
or full screen.
So, that's going to remove your notification
bar on phone devices as opposed to tablets.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And so this is the neatest way and
that's what we're seeing on this device.
If you go back before that on Android 3, so
Honeycomb devices, it's a little bit different.
We have--we have the ability to hide the status
bar and we also have the ability to go into
what's kind of a low--a low profile mode.
And so this is going to eliminate your status
bar, your notification bar on the phone devices
and it's going to make your navigation on
Honeycomb devices be those three little dots.
So, it hides as much as it can but doesn't
actually give you any extra screen real estate.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
This is what we use to call lights-out mode.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
Lights-out mode.
So, that's kind of your next best for sort
of the Honeycomb ear devices.
If you go back one step further before we
had tablet devices nearly--currently, you
had on the screen at all, was the status bar.
The way to do that, was to flag full screen,
you know, set the window layer [INDISTINCT]
flag full screen and that will remove your
notification bar and this is something which
is only appropriate to do in a very specific
circumstances in playing back video is one
of those circumstances.
And the important thing to note here for pre-Honeycomb
devices is that you have to manually add it
and remove it.
And so one of the temptations that I've seen
in a lot of apps do is they simply remove
it and you never get it back.
So, even while you're browsing when if you're
not, even doing video playback, you're going
to still have your notifications, that's infuriating.
So, what you actually want to do here is tie
this code into play and pause of your media.
So, whenever you're playing you can hide the
notifications and soon you pause, you bring
it back again.
>> NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
>> MEIER: So, shall we move?
DICE player, I think was the next app that
we wanted to take a look at it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: So, this doesn't have a feature
graphic so, it doesn't have the tablet stakes
to be featured even if we wanted to which
is...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...disappointing.
So, that should be the first action item for
those guys.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
Very disappointed to see that, but DICE player
in its implementation is actually quite nice.
Actually, I think that they've got the best
browser.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Of the ones that I've looked
up.
>> MEIER: Suddenly looks from here, very similar
as MX Player, but with the real ActionBar
which gives at the end.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know the very similar to
the MX Player mean--well sort of brings surface
as we get through this, but yeah.
It's your typical browser as we said could
be better, but the really nice thing is as
I go through the browsing experience, I have
a very predictable...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and familiar ActionBar layout,
an ActionBar UI pattern to deal with.
So, I can navigate through the ActionBar in
navigation pattern and I've got also my actions
over here.
Now, there is one thing that confuses me a
little bit.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: There's a screen for, well you
know what?
I'm going to let you guess.
This is--this little thing that looks to me,
like a monopoly house, what would you say
that, that button will do?
>> MEIER: I'll say, I would assume that, that
was a misplaced home button.
>> NI-LEWIS: Effectively navigate you to the
home?
>> MEIER: Yeah.
What you would expect when you're hitting
this button here?
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: So, they're taking you to the--to
the root navigation.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
That's what I thought too, but...
>> MEIER: Let's see what happens when I...
>> NI-LEWIS: A complete surprise.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Media full, so this is how you manage which
local folders and well, even looks like a
remote sources of being indexed for your video
[INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And I kind of felt like I did one about my
first box Wonka mix ups.
You know, candy where all the colors are wrong.
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: And the strawberry one is orange
colored and the grape one is purple, no.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Grape would be purple.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Grape would be purple.
Anyway, the point is, I felt mixed up.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: The--what this actually took
us to is a settings page for getting other
types of media.
Now, in its defense this is an awesome piece
of functionality.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right?
I can choose a [INDISTINCT] server, I can
choose an FTP server, I can take an HTTP stream.
>> MEIER: Very nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: And add them all into this.
So, if you've--if you're like me and you've
got like a lot of videos on a share--on your
Windows machine....
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...or a Linux machine at home
then, being able to connect to [INDISTINCT]
FTP is a really nice piece of functionality,
right?
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: I did test this with my Windows
machine at home and its streamed a large video
directly of that machine and that made me
super happy.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But the functionality, I don't
think I ever would have found, if I haven't
been thinking "Well gee, how do I get to the
home screen of this app?"
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Well, indeed.
And we're in kind of the special case because,
you know, we are reviewing these apps; we're
going to hit pretty much every button to see
what it does.
A lot of users are going to be even be looking
for that particular functionality, take one
look if the app going to help.
No, I can't see anywhere in--can't see anywhere
here.
I guess--I guess it doesn't do that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And then move on to next app.
We want to make sure that any--particularly,
useful functionality like this, differentiating
functionalities is really easy to discover.
>> NI-LEWIS: And while we're talking about
discovery too, this is something I noticed
a lot with the settings.
A lot of times I found apps....
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ....that have really, really
intriguing functionality and its hidden in
a piece of the settings.
Sometimes that I wouldn't even thought to
look for.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: And in some cases, its functionality
that I really, really wanted to sort of wish
was either turned on by default or perhaps
just more discoverability because there's
some really cool stuff in here that I wouldn't
have thought to look for.
Now, when it comes to playback, there's a
couple of things that I really, really like
about this application.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, I've using MX Player more
and I think you have too.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And there's really only one reason
for that and that's because MX Player doesn't
hide my notification box.
I mean, in every single other way.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: DICE Player is superior in this
playback UI.
It supports essentially the same scrubbing
motions as we saw before, including the fine
tune scrub here.
>> MEIER: Okay.
But it's not doing a real time frame preview
when we're doing [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: You're right.
[INDISTINCT] in every other way.
I was--I was exaggerating there.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: I was overly excited.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uncomfortably so.
>> MEIER: Uncomfortable excited, it's a problem.
>> NI-LEWIS: But in nearly every way and it--they--and
they do have a lot of the same and you know,
over here we got brightness, over here we've
got volume.
>> MEIER: I see that they switched that around
for MX Player.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you go to be different.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I think MX Player is actually
patented the right-hand side.
>> MEIER: That could be it.
So, you can see actually as well while we
do have to playback they've--again, sort of
half gotten right the immersive experience.
So, you can see and you probably can't see
on the video, but when it is playing back
rather than losing the navigation completely,
they're going to a Honeycomb compatible lights-out
mode and so they sort of up to date, up to
a Honeycomb but haven't taken that extra step
for Jelly Bean.
>> NI-LEWIS: Great.
And so that makes it useful on tablets because
I do get my notification bar badge.
>> MEIER: Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: But on the phone, you don't.
>> MEIER: That's exactly right.
>> NI-LEWIS: And on the phone instead, you
get a sort of fake notification bar.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: That has the time and has the
battery indicator.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But it doesn't show me any of
my notifications, which is something that
I generally like.
I also don't like the way that UI just goes
away when I'm paused.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: I would prefer that it remained.
Other than that though, it does have of course
the child lock mode that we saw before.
One thing that I really like is that, it automatically
selects to the hardware accelerated.
>> MEIER: Oh, yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: If the hardware supports it and
if the video is encoded in a way that the
hardware can decode.
So, I don't have to do it on the other app
which is think [INDISTINCT] so this really
should be hard work already.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, I didn't play with it enough
to see if it feels on any particular videos
or even if an MX Player will actually remember
defaults that would be cool too, but on the
initial, you know, first blush I think that
this is app is a little bit better.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: At playing back video.
I would like to see scrubbing.
>> MEIER: That would be nice.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: A nice.
That would be really cool.
>> MEIER: Just a little visual touches which
I think MX player have done a good job at.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
But this has really interesting features for
instance; it does have the capability to speed
up videos which is great on your more recent
this week in Android Development that you
bowed to all people that...
>> MEIER: To public pressure.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...that does as well.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: All those non English speakers
you said they couldn't understand you.
>> MEIER: Little that they know that when
I spoke it's a more reasonable pace they still
couldn't understand me.
>> NI-LEWIS: Not at all?
>> MEIER: This way I don't have an excuse.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So, the other thing that I think is just incredibly
interesting here, I'm not going to say--not
going to say too much about it, let's just
see what it does.
I press this button here, oh, my goodness,
look at that.
>> MEIER: How interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm not sure whether you love
or hate it, but I get the feeling that if
I were using my tablet for a lot of, let's
say email, road task, and I might really appreciate
having a video that I could just playback
in the corner.
It certainly appeals to me for the couch potatoes
scenario where...
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I'd like to have something
playing while I browse for something else.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Then again...
>> MEIER: I don't know what to make of this,
I'm pretty sure I would know what the framework
team would make of it.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm pretty sure they're doing
something sketchy that's going break somewhere.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
I wouldn't--I wouldn't be banking on this
one.
>> NI-LEWIS: There will be sorrow at some
point.
>> MEIER: But it's an interesting feature,
it's certainly taking things in the direction
we shouldn't think anyone else has thought
to do so, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
It's fascinating.
>> MEIER: Fair play for that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Very interesting and I think
that as I've shown this to my friends, the
people that I've shown it to you who are die
hard Android--let's say actual developers
on the framework team.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Think that it's a little sketchy.
Other people they actually think its kind
of awesome.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, yeah, you know, that will
happen.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
You know people like crystal Pepsi too.
>> MEIER: People like new coke.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Good thinking.
I love the weight.
All right.
So, let's have a look.
We don't want to spend too much more time
today.
It was supposed to a be shorter episode and
we seemed to be completely unable to mitigate
our own blabber amounts, but let's see if
we can have a look at some of the prescriptions
for these apps specific.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think its completely unfair
by the way, we're 20 minutes behind time and
it doesn't even count the five minutes that
we spent jerking off at the beginning of the
show.
>> MEIER: That's very true.
That's very true.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, aren't you glad that we're
not doing this live and we can cut that out?
>> MEIER: Very glad.
Very glad.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Let's go.
Let's talk about our results from this week's
App Clinic.
>> MEIER: Here indeed.
So, this is the prescription for CineXPlayer.
So, the big thing there was to use to audio
focus and un-pause to control the playback
rather than relying on notifications from
the system that incoming calls are happening
and those sorts of things.
We really think that they should revisit the
custom UI.
Nothing wrong with the UI particular for an
app like this which is very immersive, but
I think that almost an ActionBar but isn't
an ActionBar that includes the search control
that isn't a search control is probably something
that they will reconsider.
And the same with the custom status bar.
You know, really take the advice and handle
full screen in a way that, you know, tablet
and phone uses have come to expect that ability
to be able to hide everything and then bring
it back as soon as you're playing things.
I also wanted to point out that the Google
Play listing for CineXPlayer has a fantastic
testimonial saying how the wonderful the app
is on an iPhone.
Now that's a not entirely good practice.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know what--yeah.
I mean it--I don't--I don't think it bothers
us but it bothers our merchandising team.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Good for...
>> NI-LEWIS: Spectacularly.
>> MEIER: So, if you're building an app like
this and you want to be featured and frankly
who doesn't?
You may want to consider things like that.
There's someone on Google Play and merchandising
team who's going to look at these apps and
if doesn't have a feature graphic they're
going to pass it by.
If it's cooling out competitors it probably
going to think twice as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, prescriptions for MX Player
are considerably shorter because we both love
the app.
>> MEIER: It was a nice app, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But we'd really like to see a
better ActionBar.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
It seems like such an easy win.
You know, they're already using all of the
native Android 4.0 stuff.
They've got an ActionBar or something very
much like it in the view.
Putting it in the browser as well and give
us that experience that we used to.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
But the video playback I think in general
is really--was really great.
The only thing that wasn't jarring was that
I would go from the video playback which is
a dark theme and, you know, usually a high
contrast experience with the videos that I
watched.
And then I would be flopped directly into
this light themed browser and especially at
night, you know, if I'm watching videos in
bed or whatever that was a little bit jarring.
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: I feel like maybe a dark theme
is a better choice for some of these apps.
>> MEIER: Yeah, seems like it would make sense.
I did want to call out as well with MX Player.
One of the things that they do really well
is feasibility to the play pretty much anything
we throw at it.
We throw some pretty upscale media codecs
at it.
I was able to decode everything if not always
at full speed at least it was able to figure
it out which is really impressive.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's absolutely true.
I remember we throw a quick time animation...
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...play--video at it.
>> MEIER: And it didn't choke.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> MEIER: Which surprised me.
>> NI-LEWIS: It played very slowly but then
again so did my [INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: Exactly right.
It also passed the test--it was the only app
that we looked at that was able to play back
media which we plug into the device in any
ways.
So, whether that was native on the device,
via SD card or even by via USB key for which
I managed to dig out of a skeleton--well,
not skeleton but a cobweb string corner.
I was still able to do that.
So, that's--that was impressive.
>> NI-LEWIS: A DICE Player did a lot of things
right.
Most importantly I think it got its defaults
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: If a video could be hardware
accelerated it was.
And I think you were pointing out if a video
is very small.
>> MEIER: It automatically full screened it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Which none of the other players
did.
I was surprised.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
And you can argue either way.
You can say that they should be showing it
to you in its native resolution first and
foremost but really if you're looking at these
apps--at this--at these videos I should say
on a tablet or on a phone chances are you
just want it to be full screened.
You just want to enjoy it in its immersive
experience as possible.
So, it kind of makes sense to default that
way.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, really there--we just had
some nit.
We really liked the DICE Player playback engine
and the way that it handles defaults correctly
but we really hated the way that it hid the
notification bar.
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: And this is nit picky but we
felt like the ActionBar could use a little
bit of work when you...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...hit the back button it popped
a confirm exit dialogue.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...which I don't even know why
you do.
>> MEIER: No.
Exactly, I mean this confirm to exit is one
of my pet peeves along with the exit buttons
and exit menu items.
There really isn't need for it.
There's no need to confirm to exit just make
sure that there is no status loss when they
exit.
You know, you get the on pause, you get the
on stop, record, shared preferences it says
what movie they're watching, what the current
playback position is and then if the app gets
killed while you're in the background well
that's fine.
When you load up, load it all up full.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know I worked with a lot
of video games that were really, really concerned
about what happens when you exit but that's
because they're building this gigantic OpenGL
structures...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and they're loading lots of
texture but with this really you're recording
where you're at in the video and maybe, you
know, zoom level and volume and brightness
and...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...a few other settings that's
it because resurrecting the video playback
engine on Android is a very, very quick task.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
They're hardly reticulating any [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So, get rid of that.
Get rid of the customs status bar during the
playback.
We really rather just see the normal notification
bar and...
>> MEIER: And then that it is--because it
looks like really all this guys need to do
is take another look at the Jelly Bean APIs
because there up to date for Honeycomb, but
they haven't quite nailed it and I think they
have a look at the code samples we've given
here.
And take a look at the new Jelly Bean APIs
for this and they'll be good to go.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So, we've already shown how to handle full
screen correctly.
If they take that to heart I think they'll
have a much better user experience.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So, that's the end of the App Clinic for today.
A very special midweek episode of the App
Clinic to hopefully make out for our terrible,
terrible disasters in the last couple of weeks.
We are going to tempt faith this week by doing
two App Clinics.
We're going to be back on Friday to do an
App Clinic on shopping apps.
>> NI-LEWIS: Which we thought was going to
be about apps like Amazon or Zappos...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But then we realized they Amazon
and Zappos are the same and there are no other
shopping apps.
>> MEIER: Which is apparently what all the
viewers thought as well.
So, what we have is shopping assistance apps.
So, we've learned that people would like to
us review shopping assistance apps and that
we need to be a lot more clear when we say
what our app themes are each week.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
Well we do have some news in that area.
I won't spoil it today but when you tune in
next time we'll going to be talking a little
bit more about app themes and what will happen
to the apps after we've reviewed them.
We're very excited.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So, yeah, it's been--it's been an interesting
experience.
We have gradually increased things and so
you'll see that--or in fact you may have already
watched Nick, Roman and Adam doing a UX make
over on a couple of these apps.
And so we're going to try and find more interesting
ways of being able to take the apps that we
look at and give them a more thorough go at.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Well, thank you to everyone who nominated
apps for our video playback app-a-ton.
>> MEIER: Indeed.
>> NI-LEWIS: We really enjoyed it.
I found some apps that I didn't know about
before and thank you again for everybody who
nominated shopping apps.
Now what are we going to do after shopping
apps?
>> MEIER: I think there was some talk of celebrating
Halloween.
>> NI-LEWIS: With Halloween apps.
>> MEIER: Halloween apps.
>> NI-LEWIS: What is a Halloween app Reto
Meier?
>> MEIER: Well, I'm new to this country, so
I assume that there a huge amount of apps
designed specifically for Halloween.
How to carve a Jack O' Lantern?
How to keep track of the candy that you received
and give out?
Surely there is a huge, huge pile of apps
that people will have designed specifically
for this most sacred of all holiday seasons.
>> NI-LEWIS: I can only hope you're right
and if that's not the case what are we going
to do instead?
>> MEIER: That's a very good question.
I will probably have to look on whatever the
next category we have and see if there are
people have nominated apps for that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Now you did put up a set of cards on that
one site that you like so much.
>> MEIER: Treelor.
That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
>> MEIER: Yes.
So, we will share once again a link to Treelor
on Android Developers plus page.
>> NI-LEWIS: And for those of you who thought
like me.
We were mistaken.
It is not actually a Russian guy singing in
a weird singsong voice.
>> MEIER: Or is it?
No way to know until you sign in.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
All right, well thank you very much for viewing
yet another episode of the App Clinic.
We will be back Friday with more and don't
forget to watch on Tuesday when Roman Nurik
brings us his version of Android design in
action.
>> MEIER: Thanks for watching.
I'm Reto Meier.
>> NI-LEWIS: I am Ian NI-LEWIS.
>> MEIER: See you later.
>> NI-LEWIS: Cheers.